welcome to creator games 2. we have nate
uh
he's over courage here um he's helping
me because
i'm pretty awkward and you know he has a
box here to even out our height
hey don't expose me that hard you just
told him that's funny he's seven foot
two i'm six foot five so i have to you
know
yeah i need some help um all right well
we don't have to harp on that one
you did oh yeah all right we're just
kidding i got a knife hold on where did
you just pull out a knife from um
oh well the top part it looks like icing
oh
boy delicious it's like how do you feel
after the first two rounds
uh i don't know i'm ready for mark rober
though
that's his way of saying get the camera
off me bring it back hundreds of
thousands of dollars you'll never use
this
any other at any other point in your
life but we're both gonna win kick them
off bring it back
both of them are gonna win very good but
uh okay yeah there we go we kicked it
over to them they're here if you were
wondering they are here
so let me play this okay you know
i think up next we're hearing it a
little bit better now
cake cake it actually wow oh you want me
to check it uh
oh you're gonna chuck the apple
let them talk a little bit too oh man
there you go was that washed and
probably not
any of you boys have anything to say the
p
i have to pee too i also have to pee
they all have they all have to be they
all have to use the restaurant i don't
know if you had to bring them up for
them to tell the world they had to pee
but there you go anything else besides
your math oh well you
lost the screen time thank you glad i
brought commentators out
it's been great well mr beast is
updating the board all right here we go
the match that's been we got like so
many connections and stuff and i have no
idea what i'm doing but
it's working so far it is that's the
answer the sooner you drop out the
harder
um anyways you can move them off yo this
chat is so funny
it's literally people spamming uh who
they're gonna vote back what is going on
why are there so many people on camera
thank you all right here i'll
it doesn't matter all right this is
interesting
ah stop all right um and that
is it uh and that is it
for the first round sorry we've made it
through the first round
of competition as jimmy's getting
something out of his foot
uh that's he's not wearing shoes for
today's broadcast
you can talk about education or you
could talk about the
you know tournament we're currently
hosting with 800 000 people watching
up to you guys you're on the screen
[Music]
and it's a holistic uh you know athletic
you got to keep your body healthy to
keep your mind healthy
right yeah it's important um
i love it
hey we i think we should have done that
here today before before today's show we
would have even brought in more energy
george
george i made you a a snowflake oh
thank you that's cool that's nice of you
[Laughter]
um george before you go just what's
going through your mind
or george is gone we here are we here oh
we hear you
go ahead
no i don't think we hear him eric is
just ruthless
he just cut him off he did george out
here all right well
so jordan uh whenever
i can corona virus man all right it's
done you're coming
i don't think that's how that works
you're not the president but okay i love
it
i love it hopefully next time there you
go really it mark rover was trending
i guess so i can't eric just yielding
them out of this world
you know what it is it's just once the
losers are out he says no time
eric's like we don't care bye what's up
no no let's do another one of these see
that's why i don't pick everyone i pick
up jimmy says
that's why i don't know it's gonna be
all right and my brain is fried so i
have literally nothing
of value to add to this broadcast right
now i'm stumped i didn't from the
beginning
so all right now this is interesting um
there we go glad i invited you guys we
can
bring it back over here wait laser beam
one i do this every time
i'm not doing this anymore okay i can
handle it don't worry that's like
literally my third time doing that and
of course the back stick you just take
it okay i'll i'll i'll i'll handle it as
mr beast is breaking everything without
bracket behind us interesting chandler's
back
he's here with me right now oh i missed
all right well never mind i don't care
bring it back we don't need them
i thought it'd be hilarious if i just
hit him in the face with the bread you
were way too confident dude they're so
far
i swear they're so far away all right
anyways let's see let me
oh he almost fell off his almost fell
off my box everybody
oh she said it was a song oh how do you
remember this song
that's see make sure like check to see
who's
still here because if someone left
obviously you probably want to take
their name out of the jar
yeah because they're they're not i love
that jimmy just goes
jimmy just walks up
[Laughter]
tweet out a link to the video while
you're at it that'd be cool just listen
my money this cash in hand is on the
emilio family they're crushing it right
now
what happened to marquez oh oh oh yeah i
keep talking about marquez
all right guys guys he's still in jack
no i i'm eric i don't need you to eric i
don't need to read the names yeah we
have we have the list
he's reading the names in right here
like i know there
let's see there that was your people
send it to the moon oh it came out great
it came out great awesome nice and clear
keep that in mind if you
might want to start watching a new
channel yeah
so subscribe to me too
no seriously well you're not in the
description but it's courageous you
should thanks guys
are you guys gonna make the winner of
this uh this event
a trophy as great as this one uh no but
we got a stack of money over there
we're gonna let oh wait let's let's wait
okay this this has to be
dramatic slow-mo almost this is
the last person from the eastern
conference ten thousand short though
unfortunately
i don't think that's ten percent uh
whatever no he's gonna take it no no i
know but i think those are stacks of a
thousand or something
oh well um and like that wouldn't fill
up a briefcase
so um now we got the measurements of the
size of money out the way
he held up a sign that said close whoa i
i didn't have plans on closing the
stream but i guess no
yeah i mean congrats i could sit here
and just talk but
i don't know that's what i was it was
cool i was a little nervous leading up
to this but
it was fun a lot better than rock paper
scissors i'm so happy
this is this is actually fun um and uh
yeah i mean creator games three
you